At the end of 1929,
the Kremlin decreed that millions of
peasants from individually owned farms
will be forced into agricultural
collectives or cold causes seen in the
eyes of the bureau as pliant providers
of Soviet agricultural needs in defiance
of the facts,
so they,
the the ologists hammered out
inappropriate Marxist terminology to
explain what was going on throughout
grain producing areas.
It was said resistance to this
scientific scheme was being organized by
so called rich peasants are kulaks with
his customer brutality.
Therefore stellan decreed the
liquidation of the cool acts as a class.
We'll stand in like this idea of like
group guilt.
That was a major theme for Stella and
that meant I really didn't have to ever
pay attention to you as an individual.
I could just decide if you were a
doctor,
engineer or a Kulak or a German or
whatever.
Ethnic,
racial or educational division happened
to characterize my particular target at
the time,
and it didn't matter if you were guilty
as an individual.
That whole notion never even obtained.
It was class guilted mattered and if you
were in one of those classes,
well we're better without you.
And of course the nature of the class
just changed constantly.
But it was perfectly logical thing to
think if you believed in like historical
determinism,
if your parents were rich birch wha,
what was the probability that you are
going to be a useful part of the
workers' collective bs?
You're just to get rid of you ahead of
time so you didn't cause too much
trouble.
So then you think about these cool acts,
rich peasants,
who are these people like when we get
down to the individual level,
so you go on a village village was full
of surfs like not 40 years before.
So these are people just struggling out
of the feudal society.
Right?
And you've got some people in there
who've managed to be successful enough
as farmers,
which is no easy thing to like have a
house and maybe hire one person and you
know,
maybe have a little extra food in the
larger and a few kind of material
possession.
So these are successful people and so
you could say,
well they're the ones that actually knew
how to farm to one theory or you can say
the reason they had all this stuff was
because they stoled it from all the
other people.
Right?
And then you think,
okay,
so I marched into town,
I'm a Soviet revolutionary,
and I say,
hey guys,
you know those rich people,
they stole everything they have from you
and then you think,
okay,
which are you guys is going to listen to
that.
Well,
it's not going to be the sort of
struggling people just underneath them
who are really trying to get ahead,
right?
Because that's where they're hoping to
get.
It's going to be.
They're resentful and revengeful few who
think,
well,
the world is fundamentally unfair and
it's obvious that those sons of bitches
got what they want by stealing it from
me.
And here it turns out that if I just go
down the street and steal it back,
well not only,
not only am I allowed to do that,
but according to this new and emergent
etiology,
man,
that's the best thing I could possibly
do.
So then multiply that story by several
million participants and you have like
the first five years of the Soviet
Empire,
and so what do we have there?
The result was a catastrophic onslaught
on millions of peasant households at
first,
activists and local officials read
bullies,
right,
brutalized peasants,
forcing them to surrender their
homesteads and their possessions,
deportations,
arrests,
and killing soon followed as terror.
Generalized the violence mounted to full
scale rebellion in various places with
regular troops engaged for months.
For example,
suppressing peasant uprisings resistance
took various forms,
usually reflecting the hopeless,
desperate anguish of a doomed population
in the Ukraine.
There were even women's rebellions,
spontaneous uprisings of peasant women
who attacked the local Coco's is to
demand a return of confiscated foreign
products with a colossal impact on the
Soviet economy.
Peasants slaughtered their animals by
the millions rather than see them seized
for two years.
The fighting raged as the dreadful
process of deep Kula Ization continued
style in order to further assault on the
recalcitrant peasantry.
What conquest caused the terror famine
of 1932 Moscow rights conquest.
It's from a book called the harvest of
sorrow.
Knowingly decreed green procurement
procurement's from the Ukraine.
Analysis were exceeding by far with the
local population could produce right,
which meant that everyone who lived
there was forest in order to deliver
more grain than they had ever grown.
Communist brigades roam the countryside,
forcing agriculturalists to disgorge the
little they had been able to produce
under conditions of severe dislocation.
Grain sat unused in state reserves while
the local population starved.